very such so be given this label that
I'm betraying Hong Kong I will not do
anything that is not in the interest of
Hong Kong to the protest nurse now in
front of a Legislative Council again I
make this plea any violence will not be
tolerated by our enforcement authorities
because tolerance of violence also gives
rise to very adverse consequences we
have not done enough in engaging young
people from different backgrounds and
different sectors and after this
incident we certainly will do better
pushing through the amendments you know
at this speed that that you are doing
right now how do you still expect people
in general not just young people but
Hong Kong people to listen and still
trust the government that there is a
calm and rational way of doing things
the alternative of not pressing ahead
with the legislation will have an even
worse situation in terms of confidence
and trust is that right
of course the government could sort of
put a stop to all these things and on
the face of it we have overcome the
crisis but we are paying a huge
political price I will not shy away from
my responsibilities in introducing a
piece of legislation though we are very
convinced of the justifications that
causing this public outcry and all these
diversity within society but sometimes
as a political leader
you cannot shy away from typical
decisions